θευτή ένα νερό ένα καφέ κάτι τα σωματία να βάλουν μιαν εξτραδρατριττων πυ έχει να
κάνει είτα με μουσικίν είτε να βάλουν ακατιμίες τους να πα έξω στο ιμήχρονο είτε
να κάνουν αφςη παράληλα όλα αυτά συνδιαστικά τραβουν τον κόσμο και των διαφέρον να πάει
να περάσει έναν απόγευμα νατής έναναγονα καλθώςέρας κριβώς αν όμως πηγαίνες και ξέρεις ότι για
τρεις ώραίας δυ ώρες διώμιση εν μπορώ να χρησιμοποιήσω χώρους οιγινείς ούτε πρέπει να πάρμαζί
μου νερόν καφέ κετά λοιπά πιθανω να μινα μην πισκεστη διαδικασία να πάεις ίσως το
ενδεχόμενο να έρθουν επενδητές όπως είδαμε στο ποδόσφέρο που άλλάξε και κάποιεκάποια πράγματα στ ότι
ήλθ επεδητές έδωσαν αχρήματα σε ομάδες που παραδοσιαγάβρίσκοντα στς κατοθέσις τώρα είναι στις πρώτες ίσως
αν έλθουν επενδητές και βάλουν χρήμα σε ομάδες ίσως αλλάξει αυτικώ να και στην καλαθωσφέρο
επεδητς ευλογία η κατάρα ένα ζήτημα ντο οποίο πρέπει ανθέμα στις ζήτησης εγώ πάνταλέότι έχουμε
επενδίτεσ στον πάσκα βέβαίως και έχουμε επενδηδς οι προέδρεδος σωπατί μαστή είναι δεν είναι επενδτς
δηλαδή οι οικογένει απαβαέλινα που έχει των κεραυνώντοσα χρόνια δεν είναι πενδίδες η οικογέναι ελευκαρίτη
δνείαι πδεν είναι πενδητές η ομάδα των των ανθρώπον της ανόρθωσης οικογένει α λογιζήδη στην
αέλτα παιδία από το παραλίμνινο όλοιώση η οικογένεια κονσταντίνου τη τή είνα αυτή δενείναι πενίτς
τάξι δεν είναι με την έννια του εμπελδητ που έχει περάσει σστοόπως το ξέρουμε βάλιο
άλλο τριάτααράτααλλά τη εναι αυτή νείνι πνητες είναι πεντητές αλλατήσι με αι επενύο επιχειρηματικά όταν
κάπεις νια λεπενδησί περιμένεις να έχεις και ένα μιανάρφα απόδωσηπίσω στην επέδση που άζεις α
εγώσο λέ ότι ούτε κάν αυτοή που είαι στο ποδόσφερον γνωρίζουντε ότι δεν α θα
πάρούν κάτι πίσ και δεν ξέρω τους λόγους που βάζουν τ